when you were born the umbilical cord
was wrapped around your neck
and uh what happens is that causes a
loss of oxygen
and so it's pretty remarkable because
you didn't talk to you were six years
old were your parents concerned that you
had brain damage or that there was
something severely wrong with you
my mom was very concerned because she
has a phd in
educational psychology so she knows
exactly
where you're supposed to be at which
stage and my sisters were so
advanced for their age they were really
ahead of the curve so
when i wasn't really speaking uh she
was really concerned they everyone
thought i was deaf for a while and i
i was actually never even allowed to
know that there was anything wrong with
me
wow i never really found out later i
remember being frustrated a lot that i
would
people wouldn't understand me when i was
trying to communicate with them but
i i never knew that they were concerned
that i was
really really behind but do you remember
a time where you just didn't speak
or just felt like wow i can't make
myself known to anybody i didn't even
think about it i was not talking like
when i played with toys i would think
all the words but i wouldn't say them
out loud
so it just looked like i'm randomly
playing with toys but i had this whole
inner dialogue and story going on
the whole idea of learning martial arts
your mom was a
judo instructor right yeah she was the
first american to
win the world championships in judo in
1984. and even though you know listen to
your mom's a judo instructor your dream
was to be this great swimmer
and as you go along tragedy hits your
dad
is i guess did he go sledding with you
is that how it happened that he
injured his back yeah her whole family
went just sledding one day
and your dad got injured and uh it
affected his life
where he was told that he probably would
be in a wheelchair eventually
right that his situation would
deteriorate yeah he
pretty much deteriorated until they
said that there was nothing they could
do and
it was just going to keep going that way
until we lost him eventually so
um he'd he rather go out on his own
terms
he committed suicide and and as a little
girl
that's just got to blow your mind i mean
there's just no way to recover from that
right i mean it's just uh
it's very difficult well i didn't even
know that he was sick
my dad didn't want us to worry he
wanted us to be kids and so i thought
everything was fine and then
one day i found out it wasn't now he had
to be a strong man to be married to your
mother if your mother's a judo champion
yeah
and she could probably kick his ass
honestly right you got to be a special
kind of guy to date someone who
uh can just beat the [ __ ] out of you at
any given moment yeah
my mom told me the story once when they
were they were still dating and they
were like walking along on the beach
and he was like you know you know he's
like you can't throw me you can't throw
me
big mistake my mom bam throws him down
right in the sand
and he loved it he liked it
so you wanted to be a swimmer and then
around the age of 11 you say
screw swimming i want to be like my
mother i want to be a judo champion
does your mother try to discourage that
or is she turned on by that
no she'd try to discourage it from the
beginning she thought people would
expect too much out of me because i was
her daughter
i see and but once you made the decision
your mother helped you with judo she
started to train you right
yeah she said is this something you
really want to do and when i swam
i was with the intent that i was going
to win the olympics in it because that's
what my dad always told me and then
the whole idea was okay if this is what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna win the olympics
in it because that was what
my dad kind of put in my mind you do
something to be the best in the world at
it
and so uh your mom even when when you
were a kid
would wake you up uh by throwing you
into what an arm lock
uh yeah it was uh a strategy she took
from her old coach
yeah tell me about that what happens
you're laying in bed you're asleep
yeah what does mom do sometimes she
wouldn't do it all the time she keep me
on my toes
you know so it wasn't like every morning
i knew it was coming but
every once in a while i don't know if
she had an extra cup of coffee or what
she would wake me up and she would go
always be ready and she would jump on me
and she would either try to arm bar me
and i had to like slip out
or she would be like oh is everybody arm
bar that like i would have to like do an
arm bar
and even if i was watching tv i have
like this tick now or i can't have
uh open space behind me because she
would just sneak up behind me and throw
me over your neck and choke
like baby so your career trajectory is
you go to the olympics
you do very well you didn't get the gold
of course you probably pissed at
yourself because you're a perfectionist
in this field
and after the olympics ten thousand
dollars they give you
and uh you put it toward a car uh after
i got a bronze medal
right uh in beijing in 2008
the u.s olympic committee gave me
ten thousand dollars and i got taxed on
it so it was like
six thousand six hundred dollars or
something like that that's the crazy
thing with the olympics when you know
your russian counterparts or these other
countries are you know
paying for training these people are
rewarded a lot
they're almost really treated as pros
you're off on your own because when
you're training for the olympics in this
country
that most athletes don't have any
financial support
it's almost impossible and then you got
out you got out with a bronze
you get 10 grand like you say it gets
taxed and suddenly you're faced with
hey i'm a hero for my country and guess
what i'm going to go work at a
mcdonald's because i have
nothing i started where'd you go to work
i uh i got two bartending jobs and a
cocktail waitressing job i was at
gladstone's malibu
the redwood downtown and i was a
cocktail waitress at the
the cork on crenshawn adams and yet why
was your family so upset with you when
you became
an mma fighter like uh they they were
like it would they kind of said
we're not proud of you you that's not
what women do
women aren't supposed to be in the ring
fighting well
my mom didn't know anything about
women's mma so she but she'd seen foxy
boxing before so that was her idea of
of what it was and she was a singer
statistical consultant at usc at the
time
and so i would have pretty much gone to
usc for free
um if if they accepted me and
instead of going to college i told my
mom i wanted to be an mma fighter and
she just looked at me and said it's
stupidest [ __ ] idea ever in my entire
life